Why- why would you make this? What is the point of-
they're the same, they're just different colors.
(Brady: 1, 2 and 3 and then some have got
circles around them. Some-)
- And there's a 4 overthere.
(Oh there's a 4, we have got a 4)
- In a triangle, yeah.
- (4, triangle)
- Triangles and circles yeah. Not not super
obvious what it's for
- (No it's not popping into myhead)
- All right well maybe somebody's figured it
out by now. This- these are simultaneously
4-sided 3-sided and 2-sided diced, at
the same time. So at the same time you make one
roll and you get an answer on a 4-sided die
and an answer on a 3-sided die and an answer
on a 2-sided die. So, again, first world problem
but you've got you have to carry fewer dice
around; you don't have to carry a coin. I mean
who who has money anyway these days? So anyway,
so okay so how do you read them? So the one in
the middle, or the 1 it turns out in the middle
is the answer for your 3-sided die. So there's
a ring of four 1s around here and then you turn
this way there's a ring of four 2s around here,
and there's a ring of four 3s around here.
So well the shape here is based on a rhombic
dodecahedron but it's sort of rounded off at the-
at some of the corners. So we have these three
rings of numbers which give you the result for
the the D3, the 3-sided die.
- (1, 2 or 3)
1, 2 or 3. And you know 12 total and they're
split into three sets of four. When it lands on
one of these things you you get a circle and a
triangle on the top as well; and the circle and
the triangle - if you think about the shape of this-
these are on the sort of uh vertices with three
sides around them and those are arranged at the
vertices of a cube if that makes sense. So there's
eight of them arranged at the vertices of a cube
that you can sort of imagine being encased inside
of the shape. And so whenever it lands you get two
of the vertices of the cube up...and we have circles
on four of those eight vertices of the cube to
represent the coin, so that's the two-sided die,
and triangles represent the four-sided die because
the standard- you know shape of four-sided die is
the the tetrahedron so that's the triangle and
those are on the other four corners of that
that cube that's inside.
- (Is every permutation orcombination equally likely?)
- Excellent question. So
or another way to phrase it would be um are the
are the dice rolls independent, right? So you know-
well so the answer is not quite. So the 3-sided
die is independent of either the 2 and the 4;
but the 2 and the 4 are not independent. So- and in
fact you can see that. Suppose you you you say well
what if I get a a 4 on my 4-sided die, then
what are the possibilities for the 2-sided die?
Well there's a 1 there or you could get a 1
there or you could get a 2. So if you're going to
get a 4 on your 4-sided die then you're more
likely to get a 1 on your 2-sided die than you
are to get a 2. You can't separate them out, there
aren't enough dimensions or something but almost.
I can't imagine what sort of gambling game would
involve rolling the die and taking all the different
results and mixing them up but but yeah that's the
one thing to be careful of.
- (Okay nice)
- All right so
that's that. So again what are these for?
And uh this is not at all easy, this is very hard I
would say to figure out what these are for. They
go together, obviously they're not the same. This
is just a 3-sided die with 1, 2 and 3.
Whoops - almost - cliffhanger on the edge. So that's
a 1 because it's the one- you can see the 1 is
is sort of at the top. And if it landed this way
that would be a 3. And the way the shape is it
can't land on any of the ends cos it just it just
falls over. There we go, so that's just a 3-sided
die. This is an ordinary dodecahedron but the numbers
are weird. For example there are two 6s. So
again, why would we go to the effort and expense
of making this thing? What is the point?
- (Is 6 the only number that's repeated?)
- There's another
repeated number.
- (4 is repeated-)
- There's two 4s..
- (Nah it'simpossible)
So this is- um hello? All right, it's a poltergeist. So the
idea with these is you roll them together, you
add up the numbers - this is a 1 and a 4 so
we got 5 - and when you do that the probability,
the distribution, of the sum of those two numbers
is the same as if you roll two ordinary 6-sided dice
and added them together. This is a different way
to roll two D6.
- (That- that's pointless)
- Of coursebut-
- (That's properly pointless)
Thank you, yes. As a pure mathematician it is it is my inalienable right to do pointless things because they're fun
and because you can. When you roll two D6 and
you add them together, how likely is it to get each
different number? So you just make a grid with six
slots here for the first die and six slots here and
we can just fill it in. 7 is the most common
thing you can get out of two D6 and then it gets
less and less likely as you go the other direction.
So the the different possible outcomes are: you've
got a 2, one outcome out of 36 because there are
6 times 6 possibilities that you get. The 3,
so there's like a thing here this is 2 out of 36,
the 4 you're getting 3 out of 36 and and
so on. The 5 is 4 out of 36, 6 is 5 out of 36,
7 is 6 out of 36. So you have a 1 in 6 chance - 6 out of 36-
of getting 7 on on two D6 and then it goes back
down again. So all we have to do is come up with
some sets of numbers on the dice which have the
same numbers when you do this. There's a version of
this um for uh two cubical dice which is not the
standard numbering but also does the same thing
and and these are called Sicherman dice. Right so
the numbering on the the Sicherman dice are 1, 2, 2, 3,
3, 4 and 1, 3, 4, 5, 6 and 8. So again not the standard
numbering obviously but now we can just add it up.
Another way to number two ordinary cubical 6-sided dice - let's
just do a spot check. You're supposed to get
six 7s and 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. So you you-
- (Oh they're not in the same- they're not in the same nice rows that)
(they were in on the other die.)
- Well right, because
I mean it's it's a bit messier. So um so let's
do this one.
- (What have you called this?)
- So so wecalled these Recast 2d6. So 2d6 being notation for
take two 5 sided dice add them together. Recast as I
don't know, cast is sort of like you cast your dice?
Whatever
- (I think you need some marketing help)
- Yeahwell. So all right and then we need 12 here, all
right. So this this is 1, 2 and 3 that's easy.
So we know that there better be a 1 somewhere
on there, right, so there's a 1. Because we have
to get 2 right? And the total has to be 2. And
we've definitely got a 2. This is very dangerous,
I could screw this up. Well you can kind of figure
it out because so far this is just doing this
standard thing here. So I've got all of my 4s
already yeah; and I've got uh two of my 5s and
I've got a 6. Anyway so 4- there are two 4s.
There we go 4, 4; there are two 5s,
5, 5; and then there are two 6s. There is a
7 and there's an 8. So there's an 8 and
there's a 9 - yeah I think this is correct. All right
so let's do it - so in fast forward I'm sure.
[Very fast speech]
So we get the same thing. This is maybe a
little prettier than this, I don't know? You
imagine like contour lines right that the're that
they're climbing up and this is very sort of like
you know flat plane climbing up and these are
all a little bit more wonky somehow.
- (I know you)
(do this as a bit of a side business; is
anyone buying that? Has anyone bought them?)
Uhh I don't know. I couldn't tell you. I mean who is the
market? I mean there's certainly the marketing-
the market of like you know sort of gamer types.
Probably this is not terribly popular with the
gamer types but there's also you know math
nerds and some of them like these weird-
(I know a few math nerds. All right, all right)
- So um these are 4-sided dice right? You
can see, well this is a 1 and that's a 4
and that's a 3 but the shape is kind of
interesting. So what is the shape for? So maybe
you've seen things that look like this; these
um not dice but uh these were I think produced
by Maths Gear, so Matt Parker's thing.
- (Ah, shapes of constant width)
They are shapes of constant width. So if you
have a book you put on there then you get a
nice- yeah yeah got to get a nice book.
- (Okay so all right a book-)
- And then you
go- oh. Okay, lovely. Same thing with these. So um-
so there is a bit of a story here and uh where
these came from and the shape and all that sortof stuff.
- (So the book is always staying at the)
(same height above the table?)
- Yes yes. So if you did
this with ball bearings or spheres then you would
expect that yeah it just sort of smoothly rolls
around and it's the same thing with with these
shapes. Even though these are not spheres it still
stays con- constant height and and stable and it
does so for these things as well. So I first
heard about these like constant width 4-sided
dice on the Grand Illusions channel, they had some
of these dice that somebody had 3D printed. This
guy, Shaun Bentley had 3D printed these shapes and
so we said, oh that's a great idea, why don't we
mass produce these things rather than 3D printing;
so you know we talked to him and and he gave us
our blessing and and so on and so forth. Now there's
interesting things going on with the shapes; so if
you look at the Maths Gear tetrahedra, the Reuleaux
tetrahedra and these constant width things, not
all the edges are the same as each other. Maybe
you can see like this shape is kind of sharp
whereas this one is rounded; and that you know
works for the constant uh width property but
it's not good for the fairness of the die right?
The- it's got to have all the symmetry and the
edges that are different you know in principle
it's going to be easier to roll over this edge
than it would be to roll over a sharp edge. So
these are not going to work. So this guy Shaun
came up with a constant width shape that has all
the edges being the same. So you know they're all
rounded in the same way, rather than some of
them sharp and some of them rounder and so this
you know this works and this was the design he
went with. And we looked at this and thought, well
hold on a second there's another problem that we
need to solve. When you're making a dice for mass
produced injection molding, part of the process
the mold comes together in multiple parts and
the plastic kind of squeezes out there's like
little bits of rough stuff. And they put it in
like a tumbler to smooth out all the you know
the imperfections and make your nice you know
shiny dice. Problem is that the tumbling process is
going to do different things to that sharp corner
at the top than it is to other places on the die.
The shape would be changed different amounts in
different places in the tumbling process so we
couldn't use it. I should I should mention
by the way these are prototypes, these are not-
this is this is sneak preview, nobody nobody has
ever seen these before. Hopefully soon these
will be out, these are the prototypes. So what are
the- what are the things we need? We need the
the shape to be symmetric, it needs this you
know all the faces all the sides - the shape is-
well it doesn't have faces anymore, it's sort of
rounded. But it needs to have that that same
tetrahedral symmetry. It can just be a sphere
and the the the edges needed and the corners
needed to be rounded off. And so we asked around
a little bit and eventually somebody put us
onto this paper or by Brendan Guilfoyle and
Wilhelm Klingenberg - sorry if I'm messing
up their names - which did exactly what we needed.
So 'On C2 smooth surfaces of constant width'. So
C0 just means continuous, yeah, if it wasn't C0
then like there'd be jumps or like it will
be broken apart. C1 means that the tangent
directions match up; it doesn't look sharp
but it's not as smooth as it could be. And
C2 is saying that if you imagine like uh the
the graph of x cubed has got that nice sort of
smooth thing down there, that's the kind of
smoothness that you're getting. So it's not
completely completely smooth but it's visually
um you know quite smooth. And and the hope was
that with the tumbling process, because it's got
this extra smoothness it wouldn't get tumbled
down so much. And um yeah somewhere in here in
this paper eventually there's a nice picture
of exactly what we needed. Oh, this is looking
good, that's looking familiar right? There's all
kinds of fancy stuff in here and then yeah this
is this is like right; this is what we need. Spend
a little bit of time trying to read their paper
and figured out and there was like, why don't I
just email them? And turns out they were like, oh yeah,
oh please you know have have a go at this and
then so they gave us the code and then- and
then here they are. And uh hopefully available soon.
Thanks for watching this video. Be sure to
check out the video description for links to
more of our videos about dice, more videos with
Henry, and also links to the dice you've seen
today. You can buy them, you can check them out. I'll
include all the information you could want. Again,
that's in the video description.
- There's a drillas well with uh and it's got- it uses that triangle...